but it's kind of a remarkable thing to
deal with pressure by interpreting what
your body is experiencing as excitement
rather than nerves I've tried it I told
myself you're not nervous this is just
excitement and for me there's a little
voice inside my head that says that's BS
you're nervous but I don't negotiate
with my mind this I run this in my heart
and soul I don't let the brain run I use
my brain and let my brain used me
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's that belief nation it's heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message interpret nervousness
as excitement over to you simon Sinek I
was watching the Olympics this last
summer olympics and I was amazed at how
bad the questions were that the
reporters would ask all the athletes and
almost always they asked the same
question whether they were about to
compete or after they competed were you
nervous right and to a tee all the
athletes went no right and what I
realized is it's not that they're not
nervous it's their interpretation of
what's happening in their bodies I mean
what it what happens when you're nervous
right your heart rate starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty right you
have expectation of what's coming and we
interpreted that is I'm nervous now
what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
Olympic quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say is nervous as excited they
also the same thing no I'm not nervous
I'm excited and so I've actually
practiced it just to tell myself when I
start to get nervous that this is
excitement you know and so we're
when you used to be speaking from the
large audience and somebody'd say how do
you feel I say a little nervous now when
somebody says how do you feel like
really excited actually and it it came
from just sort of telling myself no no
this is excitement and it becomes a
little bit automatic later on but it's
kind of a remarkable thing to deal with
pressure by interpreting what your body
is experiencing as excitement rather
than nerves and it's really kind of
effective it makes you want to rush for
is rather than pull back and yet it's
the same experience so I'm gonna be
honest with you this method doesn't work
for me
when I'm about to take a big stage and
I'm about to go and give a big speech
and I'm feeling nervous I've got this
you know pit in my stomach I've tried it
I told myself you're not nervous this is
just excitement and for me there's a
little voice inside my head that says
that's BS you're nervous it just doesn't
work for me and listen Simon recommends
it I know Mel Robbins recommends it well
and lots of people have used it and has
worked for them it just doesn't work for
me so why am i including this clip it's
because the most important part here is
you need to find a thing that works for
you when you are nervous about something
it's a sign that you are about to do
something important if you are scared of
something that's the thing that you need
to go off and do if you are living your
life so safe that you're never scared
you're always running against
three-year-olds and you're 100 percent
of the time it means that you're living
your life to safe when you are nervous
and scared about something that's the
path that you need to take and whatever
strategy helps you overcome those nerves
and push through that's what you need to
embrace and go all in it so Simon does
interpret nerves as excitement here's
what I do I make it about the audience I
make it about the customers I make it
about you and not about me as soon as I
can make it about the people that I'm
trying to serve then I get more calm
then I get more relaxed then I get
actually more excited in the process so
here's a quick example I was speaking on
stage in Paris I was doing this big
event I was the keynote speaker was
closing the show and I wanted to try
different experiment normally when I get
up and do my speeches I have these
PowerPoint decks and the slides that go
alongside and I'm never reading from the
deck but they always kind of they're
good they're good time stay
to know where I'm at and if I fall off
track is easy to know where I'm at and
what point I want to come up with next I
decided that I wanted to do a
presentation with no slides so I had one
slide that was it the entire
presentation I had one slide and even
thinking about that made me nervous make
me scared what if I forget what if I
pass out what if I blank and I'm on
stage in front of all these people and
then paid money to be here I'm the
keynote speaker I want to let my
contacts down and because I was nervous
that meant I had to do it right when you
were scared or nervous about something
that's the path I had to do it and so
while I was practicing I was getting
ready I'm about to get on stage I'm
feeling the butterflies I'm feeling
nervous the guy who was coming up in
front of me didn't really do that well
on stage which made me feel even more
nervous like I need to do really well
because the last guy kind of sucked the
energy out of the room so I need to I
need to bring the energy up and the more
I'm getting nervous the more I'm talking
to myself the more it just it makes it
worse it makes it worse it makes it
worse I'm sitting there in the front row
waiting to get my turn to come on let me
come on I want to speak I got to bring
this crowd back up I want to close the
show strong the butterflies are coming
and then and then the thing that works
for me is I make it about them I make it
about service it's like I am here to
give these people a powerful message I
am here because these people need to
leave this session feeling empowered and
inspired to go off and make a difference
in their companies when they go back
home I am capable delivering that
message and I want these people to get
immense value out of this talk that's
about to come and as soon as I make it
about them as soon as I spill turd
through the lens of service to others
that's what really gets me going then it
made it a lot easier then now I'm
confident coming up on stage then I am
actually excited to get up and do the
thing and so Simon and Mel and a bunch
of others say use your nervousness and
interpret as excitement for me it's
about going through the lens of service
and helping the people that you're going
to be connecting with for others they
have their own strategies the most
important thing for you to understand is
you need to find a thing that works for
you try Simon's strategy try mine try a
bunch of others recognize that being
nervous is the path to doing great
things
being nervous is the path to allowing
you to be fulfilled and to live the life
and built the business that you want to
live and build and so figuring out the
strategy that will help you do there is
paramount now I've got a really special
bonus clip for you that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question of
the day I want to know how do you deal
with nerves
do you like Simon strategy do you like
my strategy is there another method that
you use I would love to hear from you
leave in the comments below I'm curious
but I think it'll also help everybody
else watching who has to deal with
nerves you're giving them another
strategy that they can use so give some
love to believe nation leave your
strategy in the comments thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of in spresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
but I don't negotiate with my mind this
I run this in my heart and soul I don't
look the brain run I use my brain he'll
let my brain use me everybody has a
place where they get fearful it's just
the human mind it's there it's not that
you're not gonna be fearful I think what
it really is is just again training
yourself to say I can be fearful and I
can do it anyway I don't have to get rid
of the fear I just have to dance with I
have to use the energy of it to move
myself forward and I found in the early
days I used to like gonna try to make a
decision I would do what I called my
rocking chair to test I took a
helicopter ride one time
we're flying straight across all the
people bumper-to-bumper no stop this is
the way to live what would it take to
learn how to fly a helicopter money time
energy where I'm going to fit all this
in what would life be like I'm 85 years
old I'm in my rocking chair and I flew
helicopters and I took my friends and
family took the doors awfully screamed
down on the water and we lived this life
where you could go wherever you want the
way you want Wow I looked at what that
life would be felted incredible and what
if you never learned what if you come up
with all these fears I don't have time
one of the money I don't know if I can
do it I'm like a master it and you let
the fears dominate me and I never
learned to fly a helicopter and I'm 85
in my rocking chair and I look back on
my life and I missed out on all that but
the fastest way to deal with fear is do
it anyway you don't have to feel good to
do stuff that's the illusion make
yourself do it what I've trained my
brain is when I say do it we do it
doesn't matter if it feels good doesn't
matter if it's too cold doesn't matter
if I don't feel it doesn't matter if I'm
fearful I do it anyway and when you
train yourself to do it anyway you have
a freedom most people never have and Tom
Hanks said something to me when we were
doing Saving Private Ryan that always
stuck with me which was I was asking him
about the movie a movie he did with
Jackie Gleason and I said what was it
like to work with Jackie Gleason and he
thought about it for a second he said
you know I made a decision to not be
nervous and I went what he goes I just I
knew everyone was so nervous around him
and I just said you know what I'm not
going to be nervous around him I'm just
and he and once he realized I was
treating him like you know a fellow
human being we really had this great
working relationship and it was really
good advice
you know and so you try to do that
yourself I was trying to do it with Tom
Hanks at the time
you know and and yeah and yeah it's a
you don't get anywhere being you know
genuflecting - you know somebody if you
tell yourself a story long enough you
start to believe it won't you believe it
you act like I have Tulsa what a wail
out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad
over the last week I'm murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 2:54 confidence or every
single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between thirty
seconds and five minutes long that you
start your morning with around making
you feel confident it's absolutely free
check out the link in the description
below to get access